that was awesome it was off the morning  what a cool night and I'm Rose Gregory I  was gran Patton Kim Nelson who owned the  house now thank you so much and John and  Mary Richie who were my neighbors back  when I moved when 64 and they're in  their upper 80s and they were they came  over from Brookfield most of the you and  it was a it was a when did you move out  of the house Steve went on 8 years old 8  years old 62 and I've seen that yeah a  couple of times but the hood tab the  whole crew go out thank you but no thank  you thank you for including me and  shacking that brother can I give another  shout out urn again Clemens had those  damn bratwurst so Papa John's had to  peace out there we want to thank you God  but the brats each I had occurred to me  catch a bustle relish on that back those  brats would die yes they were nice check  out our force 30 judge today  [Applause]